everything on the surface of life
changes everything you can perceive and
sense changes in some way at some point
this may sound dismal but it is not
change is not something to be afraid of
it is something that provides excitement
progression and a sense of life what's
ironic about change is how much we
appear to hate and resist it despite how
inevitably rooted and essential it is to
life we are all afraid of the
uncertainty that comes with change we
are all afraid of leaving this moment
and stepping into the next even if this
moment is not so great
it is often still better than the idea
of what can change in the next we would
rather things be not so great then go
through the risk and process of change
but regardless of our fear and
resistance to change it is inevitable we
must overcome our fear of it and embrace
it in our lives so that we can
experience its opportunity progression
and excitement like overcoming any type
of fear one must face change and
understand it in order to come to terms
with it what's interesting about change
is how we only really care to notice it
when it is sudden unforeseen and
dramatic rather when it is gradual we
barely notice or care about it we
assimilated into life and enjoy the
sense of forward motion that it brings
to us but what we must understand is
that sometimes change occurs underneath
the surface and we don't see the gradual
progression
but this change is no different it is
not something to be more fearful or
resistant to the only difference is how
we perceive and experience this
suddenness of it consider a friend or a
co-worker that you see every couple of
days let's imagine they are growing
their hair out from a very short length
to a very long length you see the
multiple times every week so you do not
notice their hair grow because the
amount each week is exceptionally minut
and unnoticeable to the naked eye you
don't care about or react to this change
and you easily accept the longer hair
now imagine an old friend or family
member whom you don't see too often this
person is also growing their hair out
from a short length to a long length the
last time you saw this person their hair
was very short now after a long period
of time you are seeing them and their
hair is significantly longer when you
see them the new change is jarring and
you are likely to have a difficult time
accepting it right away life changes and
grows like hair millimeter by millimeter
but when we only see the change in
centimeters or meters it shocks us and
we resist it we accuse people systems
and ideas of being fake disingenuous or
impractical although there are cases
where this may be true it is important
that we do not jump to such conclusions
as a result of our fear of change
we must understand that change is always
happening and just because it appears
sudden to us does not make it negative
life is in constant flux and by
resisting change we are resisting life
we must stop and consider changes
essence to life and not let fear get in
the way of embracing and enjoying it
thank you for watching if we found
enjoyment and value in this video please
give it a thumbs up share your thoughts
in the comments below and if you are not
already be sure to subscribe to our
Channel we are constantly coming out
with new videos to help you experience
life with clarity and Wonder